[Music]
[Music]
house of the dragon a game of thrones
prequel show is coming in 2022 on hbo
and targaryen dragons are coming with it
it'll feature around 20 dragons
and in the part 1 i covered many of them
we start part 2 with the most beautiful
targaryen dragon sunfire
sunfire known as sunfire the golden was
the mount of aegon the second targaryen
during the dance of the dragons he is
one of the dragons hbo shared in their
announcement few days ago
according to some sources sunfire was
the most beautiful dragon ever seen up
on the earth
sunfire had gleaming gold scales and his
flames were golden as well
during the siege of rook's nest reigning
targaryen arrived
riding the large older red dragon melees
to attempt to leave the siege of the
castle
this was all a trap however as the
greens had kept two of their own dragons
hidden
and in reserve so they could take milies
in an uneven fight
aegon ii appeared riding the younger but
strong sunfire
and his younger brother eamon targaryen
also attacked riding massive agar
the last of the first generation
targaryen dragons
reinis could not prevail against such
odds yet she did not flee
but flew head on to meet her attackers
miley's was still so
large and powerful that she put up a
brutal fight
when the dust settled miles was dead and
vegard was relatively unharmed
but sunfire had been nearly killed and
permanently maimed
melis managed to nearly rip one of his
wing arms completely from his body
and as for aegon ii he was left
horrifically burned
and with multiple broken bones sunfires
survived the battle
but the world's most beautiful living
dragon was left crippled and heavily
scarred
just like its rider aegon aegon and
sunfire reunited at dragonstone
when some fire arrived he fought and
killed a remaining riderless dragon grey
ghost
although he took yet more wounds in the
process when aegon finally rode sunfire
again
he was attacked by daemon's younger
daughter bayla riding the dragon
moondancer
even younger dragon barely large enough
to carry the 13 year old girl
moondancer was quick however while
sunfire was still half crippled and
slowed by his injuries
therefore they were evenly matched and
their duel was ferocious
it culminated when sunfire tackled
moondancer in midair
and drove her into the ground below his
larger size meant that he survived a
fall while she was killed
nonetheless sunfire was mortally injured
by this fight
and would never fly again sunfire died
soon after
despite being one of the younger dragons
in the dance
sunfire actually shared the highest
dragon vs dragon kill count with the
massive agar herself
two individual kills and one assisted
both sunfire and vogar died as a result
of their third dragon fights
for that matter they were the only two
dragons in the dance whoever lived
throughout dragon vs dragon fight and
lived
most dragons in the war were actually
killed by human armies
or died in mutual kills in their first
battle against another dragon
next we have stormcloud who was a young
male dragon bonded with king aegon the
third targaryen
aegon used stormcloud to escape an
ambush at the sea
prince sagan managed to reach
dragonstone clinging desperately to his
dragon's neck
stormcloud had been terribly wounded as
he fled
when he arrived the dragonstone stubs of
countless arrows were embedded in his
belly
and there was a scorpion ball through
his neck stormcloud died within an hour
he is seeing as the hot blood gushed
black and smoke from his wounds
after stormcloud's death aegon would
never fly again
now we come to the most epic strongest
fiercest and battle hardened dragons
demons characters and again aemons
vegard
the other dragon hbo teased in their
announcement was daemon's characters
characters was the dragon ridden by
prince daemon targaryen during the dance
of the dragons
a veteran of many battles he was known
as the blood worm for his red scales
carraxis was one of the older and larger
dragons during the dance of the dragons
daemon targaryen rode characters in his
frequent campaigns in the stepstones
as a result characters was not only one
of the larger dragons during the dance
but the most battle hardened and
experienced in more
indeed only vegard had been ever ridden
in major wars before
during aegon's conquest but while
formidable
vegar had not been used in combat in the
years leading up to the dance
the way that charaxes was opposing
armies for known to often simply flee
or surrender when characters approached
when rhaenyra captured king's landing in
a surprise attack
daemon wrote characters in the assault
while rhaenyra road cyrex
later in the war aegon the second's
younger brother eamonn targaryen
resorted to a one-man war-riding vegar
burning out much of the riverlands damon
hunted him for a long time on characters
aided by other dragon riders and their
dragons but eventually he returned alone
to harrenhal
vading as a challenge for aemond to
arrive
carraxis was formidable but vagar was
twice his size
nearly as large as valerian had been
during the war of conquest
facing him alone was the only way for
daemon to drove a car
out however as eamonn had avoided
ambushes by multiple other dragons
eamonn arrived exchanged his final
challenges to daemon
then both took to the air on their
dragons the resulting battle above the
god's eye was one of the most
epic dragon vs dragon fights of the
entire civil war
as two of the greatest living dragons
fought in the air
their shrieks shattered every remaining
window in the castle
and could be heard for miles around
their fire breath filled the skies so
that fishermen in the lake thought that
the whole sky was aflame
in the end characters dived down from
the sun on aemon's blind side
due to his missing eye characters
slammed into vegar and they both
continued to fight in free fall
vegard tore out charax's belly and used
her massive jaws
to rip one of his wing arms completely
off but characters
sank his teeth into the guard's throat
and maintained a death grip
as the two dragons grappled damon rose
from his saddle and made stunning
meet their leap from his dragon to
aymond on the guard's
wielding the valyrian still sword dark
sister which had once been carried by
vegard's previous rider
visenya targaryen demon thrust his blade
through aemon's empty eye socket
the force of his impact as he landed
driving the sword through the back of
aemon's head
both dragons plummeted into god's eye
below both the dragons and both the
dragon riders died
by the end of the day in scene 131 ac
only four dragons remained alive
ship stealer the cannibal and silver
wing who had been born years before the
war
and the dragon morning which had hatched
during the war
in other words only one dragon who
fought during the dance of the dragon
silver wings survived
dragon morning was born after the war
while the other two sheep stealer and
cannibal were wild dragons that lived on
dragonstone
sheep stealer was a wild male with a
taste for mutton
the small folk of dragonstone named it
for a self-evident reason
ship steelers coloring was an ugly mud
brown he was not aggressive toward human
unless provoked
but could be vicious and ill-tempered he
had a taste for mutton
while he devoured an occasional sheep
dog he never harmed a shepherd
the cannibal got his name for practicing
cannibalism
feasting on dead dragons newborn dragons
and dragon eggs he was one of three
completely wild dragons dwelling on
dragonstone
the cannibal was black as coal with
menacing green eyes
he was the largest and oldest of the
wild dragons
that's all that was left of 20 dragons
the targaryens had had
just a year and a half ago and they
would soon die as well
archmaester marvin holds that the order
of maesters
with their sacred goal to suppress magic
was responsible for the extinction of
dragons
the word is they poisoned the last of
the dragons
there were still many dragon eggs left
after the war
and at least one of those hatched the
large dragon was a sick and mishap and
thing
and she died young in month 53 ac during
the reign of king aegon iii
targaryen which earned him the nickname
dragonbane
she had been a green female small with
withered wings
many feudal attempts were made to revive
dragons
aegon iii targaryen the dragonbane had
nine mages across the narrow sea
to use their magics in attempt to hatch
remaining dragon eggs
the pious king baylor the first
targaryen attempted to hatch his zag by
praying over it
aegon iv targaryen ordered pyromancers
to build seven mechanical dragons that
shot the jets of wildfire hundreds of
men died in a failed attempt to use them
to invade dorne
the tragedy of summerhall resulted from
the attempt
of king aegon v targaryen to hatch
dragon x
the mad king pretended he was a dragon
using wildfire to burn his enemies
and believing he would become a dragon
after he dies
none of these attempts brought dragons
back until daenerys
ultimately the reason targaryens lost
their dragons and thus their power was
the dance of the dragons
so many dragons had died in the war that
the targaryens could not maintain a
stable breeding population
and few survivors became inbred and
sickly fortunately however the key event
of house of the dragon is the exact same
event which led to their extinction
the targaryen civil war the dance of the
dragons
and we'll get to see them all on screen
lots of dragons a lot of epic dragon
battles
all of that and more this game of
thrones prequel series house of the
dragons brings in 2022 on hbo
let me know your thoughts about
everything the pretty cool its
characters
the mighty dragons and their epic
battles in the comments section down
below
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace